ام جلود
الفاصل بين مناطق الاكراد حيث واقف وبين
مناطق المعارضه كما تظهر في الصوره هذا هو
الجدار الذي يفصل او بوابه المعبر التي
تفصل بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه ومناطق
المعارضه في شمال غرب البلاد لا يزال
الوضع على حاله دون اي تغيير لم تدخل واي
واحده من الشاحنات التي ارسلتها الاداره
الذاتيه وعددها هنا في المعبر كما تلاحظ
30 شاحنه محمله
بالوقود اي مادتين البنزين والمازوت
المطلوبه بشكل سريع في المناطق المتضرريه
ليشحها هناك ايضا هناك سبع شاحنات محمله
بالمواد الاغاثيه موجوده مقدمه من الاهالي
ولم تدخل حتى الان
يتوقع ايضا ان تصل خلال يعني ساعات 42
شاحنه محمله بالمواد الطبيه والاغاثيه
مقدمه من منظمات المجتمع المدني والاهالي
الى هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 100 شاحنه
هنا في معبر ام ام جلود من المفترض ان
تدخل الى مناطق المعارضه ليس ببعيد من هنا
نحن يعني على بعد حوالي 10 دقائق من معبر
التائهه وهو معبر ايضا تتواجد فيه 100
شاحنه اخرى اضافه الى شاحنات وسيارات
اسعاف ارسلتها الاداره الذاتيه ويفترض ان
تصل الى مناطق النظام في حلب